the Whitney and Betty McMillan Center
for international and area studies at
Yale Fosters a deeper understanding of
the world and its people through
research education and international
study McMillan advances learning in and
across societies and disciplines with
the goal of creating a more informed
inclusive and flourishing
world
McMillan brings uh disciplinary breadth
and uh linguistic religious cultural
depth uh to the study that really
reflects all of the university schools
and all of uh the rich diversity in the
faculty of Arts and Sciences it provides
resources for all of the students and
faculty to do their own research and
teaching it provides uh a convening
point for faculty across the university
whatever their areas of interest to meet
each other to bring their different
disciplinary and area studies
approaches uh to the study of uh
particular issues whether those issues
are historical uh of perennial concern
or contemporary issues I began the
prologue to my new book The motherhood
on Ice by doing a little bit of a
comparison like what's happened in the
Middle East gender relations are
improving people really desire hope wish
want to be together in marriage and have
children loving children wanting that
for the most part what's happened in
America where those Ambitions seem to be
sort of in Decline you know whenever we
talk about Buddhism and we have the
certain set of assumptions right
Buddhism is about celibacy monastic
Community meditation and Rich
enlightment um I question how much we
know
uh by assuming uh Buddhism as such if we
bring in this very interesting family
Buddhism into the picture
then how can you define Buddhism and
part conversation is on
transitions you know post carbon word
transitions we need to think more
carefully about transition for who post
carbon for who what happens to these
communities in places such as the Niger
of Nigeria the fact that we move away to
renewable energy from oil does not
address the problems of communities in N
Delta how can we work on this aspect of
social justice how might we work on that
aspect of repairing the past to the
extent we can how might we work on that
policy question by doing more history
beneath it um how should universities
look at their own past this area of
research which until recently used to be
on the margins of Russian literary
studies has gained in prominence and
importance in the wake of Russia's war
in Ukraine this war has
made clear to many in my research
Community but also to most people in the
west that we need to do much more to
understand the Imperial dimension
of Russian culture so development
economists generally are uh working on
the question that why some countries are
poor and others are not and within that
broad set of questions my work um uh a
lot of my research agenda has focused on
the question why are people reluctant to
sometimes do things that appear to be
good for them that appear to uh be
helpful to improve their livelihoods M
Millan is a community of choice uh in
the sense that if you're a professor in
a department that is highly theoretical
or doesn't have anybody else who shares
your particular
geographic area of interest that you
find that part of yourself and others
that you can discuss things related to
your area of Interest here at McMillan
the combination of area studies interest
or programmatic interests that are
international together with what they
get in departments really makes our
faculty and our students uh feel happier
uh and more productive and gives them a
lot of intellectual sustenance along the
way when I joined Yale in
2017 I turned to cl to the Council on
Latin American and iian studies looking
for other faculty uh or members of the E
community that serve Language and
Cultural ties with me but what it has
happened is that I I have been exposed
to many different diverse research in
Latin America and my thirst to learn
about the region has increased and it
has gained prevalence in my teaching too
my work has focused uh particularly on
environmental history and the history of
migration and my work is sort of evenly
divided between looking at South Asia
and looking at southeast Asia being at
McMillan where there are so many
scholars including graduate students in
postdocs who do fieldwork-based
scholarship has been very exciting
because I feel like there are many
points of alignment and a real shared
sensibility in a belief that it's really
important to to talk to people
to understand the problems that we're
studying from multiple perspectives it
is is a real privilege to meet such a
group of smart uh diverse uh students at
a key stage in their lives to work with
them to teach them to learn from them
and then to keep up those relationships
after they leave yell you know there's a
class I teach called You Know The Credo
Paradox and the social dimensions of
evolution and the students ask me so why
just do the community outreach why don't
you make them active knowledge
co-producers so
why do you need a PhD to identify your
stone tool on on on your farm and why do
you need a PhD to identify a
foret and I thought hm that's
interesting and I tried it out and it's
given us amazing amazing results here at
Yale often engaging students in your
research or teaching a course about the
kinds of things you're doing actually
engages the students at a higher level
than if you were to teach a kind of
survey course or service type course um
so it's a real dream to be able to share
brand new ideas with students and
actually those students will transform
the quality of the work that we're doing
right um at the same time I think the
students really enjoy being able to be
in the mix as Cutting Edge research is
being
[Music]
developed